I didn't get a haircut I'm just looks
ort loves love hey guys it's time for my
mid-market even though it's kind of
towards the end of the month but hey
that's okay
I still like these things anyway uh I
should just become a musician already
god dammit let's begin first thing that
you see out yeah kiss yeah this is
another item that I was given by Wendy
jdi's who helped me shoot now that you
guys all know it she was the hair
stylist on the shoot for my book yeah
she gave me this brush which is like a
wet brush it's not wet it's very dry
it's a brush that you're supposed to
wash your wet hair with specifically so
that doesn't like break and do bad
things and I was like I know their
product that was created because they
thought they could convince us that
there was a need for this or I tried it
and it works it works really well when
your hair is wet it doesn't tangle as
much sorry Disney movie next dish - yeah
yeah this is Cheadle's creamy eye
treatment with avocado why would you put
wacom only on your face I don't know but
it works
doesn't sound like I would cut Oh smells
like face cream just put it under your
eyes does it really do anything I don't
know but it makes me believe that
something's happening tiny time machines
are going under my eyes next this stuff
he's yeah he's yeah I probably said this
on a favorites video before but this
stuff I really like it's Neutrogena
micro-mist airbrush sunless tan it's
Tanima can wow
ring-ring Brothers Barnum & Bailey
Circus I'm not available sorry ever very
busy schedule this is the mist that you
spray on your body after you get out of
the shower or even when you're just dry
in general and it tans your skin no rub
application and the opposite of what he
said next bees you see a QCs yeah these
are given to me by a woman named
Elizabeth who was the stylist for my
book shoot shout out Punk
these are Pumas that are black with a
little heel in there and they make me
feel urban and cool and sophisticated
and now next this you see yeah you see I
this is the book that I just wrote you
can go to Grace's guide book calm and
preorder it I like it because I made it
that's what my mom says about me next
audible.com you see everything you see
it you get it auto calm is a website for
downloading audio books they've over
150,000 and audiobooks available I can
barely count to 15 honorable is sweeping
the YouTube nation a lot of people shout
them out it's because youtubers don't
like to read we like to be read too high
this month and listening to Chelsea
Handler's are you there vodka because I
wanted to be free inspired by a lady
that wrote a book also you guys get
something too you can download your
first on your book for free using the
link audible.com slash Grace also say
what's the link again grace audible.com
slash Grace hold for camera now that
next this IndieGoGo campaign you CIBC a
keys yet you see it it's called jet ski
for goats
it's a comedian named Kurt Braunohler
who is doing an IndieGoGo campaign to
send goats to families in Africa he's
jet skiing from Chicago to New Orleans
yes he's gonna ride a jet ski down the
Mississippi River and are using an
IndieGoGo campaign so that you can spend
five hundred goats to one thousand
African families and they're trying to
raise Oh 50 to try to raise $50,000 it's
just launched and the link will be down
below but I really think
the hilarious project that you guys
should contribute to because it's the
most dumb way to be cool to the world
good job cart okay that is it for my
favorites this half months ish / later
in the month
ish I hope you enjoyed them why I don't
know races guidebook calm I apologize
that this is how I'm going to be doing
what you are not on the show I didn't
know I was pregnant why would you do
that